well I'm voting for Hillary Clinton I've
always been a fan of hers not just now
but she knows the job in our first
african-american president and I could
add to my history by seeing our first
female president take office I do think
that Hillary would come and help the
community I would hope she would not
only I believe she's real about what she
wants to do but she has to experience on
foreign policy you know another thing so
I'm Willie with her we need someone who
knows what's going on
I think the Republicans fear her too and
they don't want her in the office
because I'm question she's staying up to
you know if I can fight for her people
all of us and that's what i mean by that